I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Oh my God. I'm here with my BFF. We're gonna do this. This is so cool. We are hanging out talking about The Office. Jenna, who is the person you want to sit next to in any high school chemistry class, she is the note-taker. You don't watch Game of Thrones, so you will miss this reference. You would be like, Jenna Fisher, first of her name. Keeper of the notes
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们一起演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在，我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有当时身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。天哪。我和我的好闺蜜在一起。我们要开始录了。这太酷了。我们聚在一起聊《办公室》。珍娜，如果你想在任何高中化学课上坐在谁旁边，那个人就是记笔记的人。你不看《权力的游戏》，所以你会错失这个梗。你会说，珍娜·费舍，她的名字的首位。笔记的守护者
of the records. I don't watch Game of Thrones, but I appreciate that. Okay. Well, you would be keeper of the notes. And she has made some really great notes. And we both went back and re-watched which episode, Jenna? Today, we are discussing the basketball episode. This is season one, episode five. It was written and directed by Greg Daniels. That's right. Should we give a synopsis of the episode? I know you want to, Jenna.
记录的守护者。我不看《权力的游戏》，但我很感激这一点。好吧。好吧，你将是笔记的守护者。她做了一些非常棒的笔记。我们俩都回去重新看了哪一集，珍娜？今天，我们要讨论篮球这一集。这是第一季第五集。由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧和导演。没错。我们要不要对这一集做个剧情简介？我知道你想，珍娜。
I wrote it. Keeper of the notes. Keeper of the notes. I wrote it down. Do it, lady. I wrote down a synopsis. She did, y'all. She typed it out. Okay.
我写的。笔记的守护者。笔记的守护者。我写下来的。干吧，女士。我写了一个剧情简介。她真的写了，各位。她打出来的。好吧。
In this episode, Michael challenges the guys in the warehouse to a basketball game against the upstairs sales staff. The warehouse workers led by Daryl want to make it a friendly game, but Michael insists there be a prize for their winner or, more accurately, a punishment for the losers. Michael suggests the losers have to work on Saturday, and then he taunts Daryl with chicken sounds until Daryl grees. Correct. But things will get more interesting in this episode. That's not where it ends, Angela. I know.
在这一集中，迈克尔向仓库里的男员工发起挑战，让他们与楼上的销售人员进行一场篮球比赛。以达里尔为首的仓库工人想要进行一场友谊赛，但迈克尔坚持要求获胜者必须有奖品，或者更准确地说，对失败者的惩罚。迈克尔建议失败者必须在周六加班，然后他用鸡叫声嘲弄达里尔，直到达里尔同意。没错。但这一集的事情会变得更有趣。事情并没有就此结束，安吉拉。我知道。
This is not end of there. Here's another dun-dun-dun paragraph. Yes, things get more interesting because Pam's fiance, Roy, works in the warehouse. Oh, snap. Yes. So we find out that she is caught between her office crush, Jim, and her actual fiance, Roy. Who's she going to root for? Upstairs or downstairs? I don't know.
这不是结束。这里还有一段“咚咚咚”的悬念。是的，事情变得更有趣了，因为帕姆的未婚夫罗伊在仓库工作。哦，天哪。是的。所以我们发现她陷入了办公室暗恋对象吉姆和她实际的未婚夫罗伊之间。她会支持谁？楼上还是楼下？我不知道。
Let's start with some fast facts. It is your favorite part. You know it is. Fast fact number one. This was Greg Daniels' directorial debut of the office. Not just any debut of directing, right? Of all directing. So not just of the office, but his debut debut. Now, he told me he had directed actors before for Voices on the Simpsons and King of the Hill. He created King of the Hill for anyone who doesn't know that.
让我们从一些快讯开始。这是你最喜欢的部分。你知道是的。快讯一号。这是格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导《办公室》的导演处女作。不仅仅是某个导演处女作，对吧？是所有执导的处女作。所以不仅是《办公室》，而是他真正的处女作。现在，他告诉我，他以前曾为《辛普森一家》和《山丘之王》中的角色配音指导过演员。不了解的人都知道，他创作了《山丘之王》。
But this was his first time doing on-camera directing. He would go on to direct 12 more episodes of the office, but this was the first. Yes. And I remember him showing up in his New Balance sneakers, his gray New Balance sneakers, and his like khaki pants. Greg always wears anything he got for free. So like his shirt might have said King of the Hill, his baseball hat might have said the Simpsons. Mindy Kaling used to joke. He just wore all his swag all the time. But he showed up so giddy and excited. His enthusiasm and love for this show and this world and characters, it was just so contagious. I just loved it so much. It made me excited.
但这这是他第一次进行现场导演。他后来继续执导了另外 12 集的《办公室》，但这这是第一次。是的。我记得他穿着 New Balance 运动鞋出现，他灰色的 New Balance 运动鞋，还有像卡其裤一样的裤子。格雷格总是穿着他免费得到的任何东西。所以他的衬衫上可能写着《山丘之王》，他的棒球帽上可能写着《辛普森一家》。明迪·卡林曾经开玩笑说。他总是穿着他所有的周边。但他出现时显得那么晕头转向和兴奋。他对这个节目、这个世界和角色的热情和热爱，简直太具有感染力了。我太喜欢了。这让我很兴奋。
Fast fact number two. This is the episode where we introduced the character of Daryl. That's right. Craig Robinson. Now we see him for the first time in the Alliance. He's watching Dwight bust out of the box, but this is the first time he speaks and this is the first time we learn his character name. Right. This establishes him as a character on the show. Now I was emailing with Allison Jones, our casting director, because I wanted to know how did you find Craig Robinson? He is so amazing. And we knew that if the show went
快讯二号。这是我们引入达里尔这个角色的那一集。没错。克雷格·罗宾逊。现在我们在《结盟》中第一次看到他。他看着德怀特破箱而出，但这是他第一次说话，也是我们第一次知道他的角色名字。没错。这确立了他作为剧中角色的地位。现在我一直在给我们的选角导演艾莉森·琼斯发电子邮件，因为我想知道你是怎么找到克雷格·罗宾逊的？他太棒了。我们知道，如果这部剧继续下去
on that this was a character who was going to recur, but who wasn't in the first couple of episodes, Greg had talked to me about how he was going to fill out the world of the office and we were going to really get to know some of the people down in the warehouse. He was going to introduce this character of Daryl as being one of Roy's friends that they work in the warehouse together. And so Allison had to cast this person who we knew was going to recur like Roy. She told me that she had seen him on a TV show called Lucky. Right. She did with John Corbett. So she said from there she had cast him in some small roles
发展下去，这将是一个会再次出现的角色，虽然在前几集中没有出现，但格雷格曾跟我谈过他将如何充实《办公室》的世界，我们将会真正了解仓库里的一些人。他将引入达里尔这个角色，作为罗伊的朋友之一，他们在仓库一起工作。所以艾莉森必须挑选一个我们知道会像罗伊一样再次出现的演员。她告诉我，她在一个叫《幸运》的电视节目中见过他。没错。她和约翰·库萨克合作过。所以她说从那里开始，他在一些小角色中出演过
on Arrested Development and Curb Your Enthusiasm because she also cast those shows and she brought him in to audition for the office. She's the reason why Craig ended up on our show. And Craig was very sought after in comedy circles. Like, I feel like that was a really big get for us. Oh, for sure. Yeah. I mean, he's a huge comedian.
在《发展受阻》和《抑制热情》中，因为她也为这些节目选角，她把他带进来为《办公室》试镜。她就是克雷格最终出现在我们节目中的原因。而且克雷格在喜剧圈非常抢手。就像，我觉得这对我们来说是一个非常大的收获。哦，绝对的。是的。我的意思是，他是一个巨大的喜剧演员。
He's so funny and so talented. And so nice. And so nice. It was everybody on our show so nice. I feel like they did us this wonderful service of casting really talented people but who were all really nice to each other. We were really lucky because we've both worked on other shows since where it is not the case. We were like, oh, wow, we were really lucky. Really, really lucky.
他太搞笑了，也太有才华了。而且人很好。人也很好。我们剧组的每个人都那么好。我觉得他们为我们做了一件很棒的事，那就是选用了非常聪明有才华但彼此都非常好的人。我们真的很幸运，因为我们俩后来在其他节目中工作过，情况并非如此。我们当时就想，哦，天哪，我们真的很幸运。真的，真的很幸运。
Okay. Are you ready for our last fast fact? Yeah. In the very early moments of this episode, you see the boom microphone dip down into frame. Did you catch on a little boom? I did. Now, normally you would never allow this on television. Right.
好吧。你准备好听我们最后一个快讯了吗？是的。在这集的最初几分钟里，你会看到吊杆麦克风探进画面中。你捕捉到那个小吊杆了吗？我捕捉到了。现在，通常在电视上你绝不允许出现这种情况。没错。
But on our show, this was considered gold. We kept this stuff in. Like, you never not used a take. That was funny. Right. It's just because you saw the boom microphone or anything, any quote unquote mistake that would normally get cut out of another show. Right. We used it. Because you want it to feel like the documentary.
但在我们的节目中，这被认为是黄金素材。我们把这些东西保留了下来。就像，你从来不会不使用一个镜头。那个镜头很有趣。没错。只是因为你看到了吊杆麦克风或者任何诸如此类的错误，这些错误通常会在其他节目中被剪掉。没错。我们用了它。因为你想让它感觉像纪录片。
Like an authentic documentary. Right. This was really important. So I thought that was kind of a cool little thing. That is cool. Our boom operator was named Nick Carbone. Yeah. And one of my favorite things is when sometimes he would get the boom in the shot, we would yell, you got Carbone. Carboned.
就像一部真实的纪录片。没错。这真的很重要。所以我觉得这是一个很酷的小细节。那真的很酷。我们的收音师叫尼克·卡博尼。是的。我最喜欢的事情之一就是，有时当他把麦克风拍进镜头时，我们会大喊，你中卡博尼了。卡博尼化了。
You got Carboned. And then we also started making up a song called Boom Shadow, Boom Shadow. Listen, young kids, Google it. That is an old song. Angela, I have to share something else about Nick Carbone, our sound guy. Okay. So Nick Carbone put a microphone on me every day for nine years. Yes, he did. It was a very intimate thing to Mike, an actor.
你中卡博尼了。然后我们还开始编一首歌叫《吊杆阴影，吊杆阴影》。听着，年轻的孩子们，去谷歌一下。那是一首老歌。安吉拉，我必须分享关于尼克·卡博尼的另一件事，我们的录音师。好吧。所以尼克·卡博尼连续九年每天都在我身上别麦克风。是的，他确实这么做了。对于一个演员来说，这是一件非常亲密的事情。
Oftentimes, you know, I was in that pencil skirt and if I was standing up, we would sometimes have to put a leg wrap around my upper thigh to hide the microphone pack and then very delicately weave a microphone wire through underneath my bra, up my blouse. And Nick Carbone was the person who did this every day. For me too. For me too. Every day. It was an intimate relationship you form with the person who mikes you every day.
通常情况下，你知道，我穿着那条铅笔裙，如果我站着，我们有时不得不把绑腿缠在大腿上，把麦克风发射器藏起来，然后非常小心地将麦克风线穿过文胸下方，一直穿到衬衫上。而尼克·卡博尼就是每天都做这件事的人。我也是。我也是。每天。你和每天给你别麦克风的人之间会建立一种亲密的关系。
Here's something that would happen though. Those leg wraps, they closed via Velcro. Yes. They were a Velcro leg wrap and Pam wore pantyhose and I would get a run in my pantyhose. And I would have to change my pantyhose four to five times a day. The wardrobe people, they would put four or five packs of pantyhose in my trailer because they knew that inevitably I would get a run from this Velcro, which was also itchy and uncomfortable.
不过，接下来会发生这样的事。那些绑腿，它们是通过魔术贴闭合的。是的。它们是魔术贴绑腿，帕姆穿着连裤袜，我的连裤袜会勾丝。我不得不一天换四到五次连裤袜。服装部门的人会在我的化妆车里放四五包连裤袜，因为他们知道我不可避免地会被这个魔术贴勾丝，而且它也很痒很不舒服。
Do you know what Nick did for me? I do know what he did for you, but you tell them. Okay. Here's what he did. He came up with a special leg wrap invention. Yes. Where he created a leg wrap that used bra hooks. It was like a bra.
你知道尼克为我做了什么吗？我确实知道他为你做了什么，但你告诉他们。好吧。他是这么做的。他想出一个特殊的绑腿发明。是的。他创造了一个使用文胸搭扣的绑腿。它就像一个文胸。
It was like a bra hook. A bra strap. Yeah, like a bra strap closure so that when he hooked it onto my leg, my pantyhose wouldn't run and I wouldn't have to change my pantyhose so often. And it worked. It was brilliant. Here's the other thing he did. He knew that I like to really go for it at the holidays.
它就像一个文胸搭扣。文胸肩带。是的，就像文胸肩带扣一样，这样当他把它扣在我的腿上时，我的连裤袜就不会勾丝了，我也用不着那么频繁地换连裤袜了。而且管用。这太绝了。还有一件事他做了。他知道我喜欢在假期里放飞自我。
I mean, I like to eat the pies and the many turkeys and all of the stuff. You love some holiday eating. I love the holiday eating. And I would often come back from the holidays a good full size larger than when I left. So Nick Carbone put like a bra, there were three different settings. Whenever if it was post holidays, pre holidays, maybe I was working out real hard for a movie role so that it always fit me because that was the purpose of the Velcro was that you could kind of Velcro anywhere.
我的意思是，我喜欢吃派、各种火鸡和所有这些东西。你喜欢在假期大吃大喝。我喜欢假期大吃大喝。我经常在假期结束后回来，比离开时长胖了整整一码。所以尼克·卡博尼做了一个像文胸一样的装置，有三个不同的档位。每当假期过后，假期之前，也许我在为一个电影角色努力锻炼，这样它总是适合我，因为魔术贴的目的是你可以随处粘贴。
So he made this adjustable leg wrap for me and we called it the Jenna and he kept it in my kit. It was so cool. And then you know what? After the office was over a couple years later, I got a job on an ABC show called splitting up together and when I walked on the set for the first day, they introduced me to the sound team and it was Nick and I am tearing up just thinking about it. There he was again.
所以他为我制作了这个可调节的绑腿，我们称之为“珍娜”，他把它放在我的工具包里。这太酷了。然后你知道吗？《办公室》结束几年后，我在 ABC 的一个节目《分居两地》中找到了一份工作，当我第一天走进片场时，他们把我介绍给录音团队，那是尼克，一想到那我就要落泪了。他又在那里。
So the only person who has really ever miked me for television is Nick Carbone and he had saved my special leg wrap. That is so sweet. I just love him so much. I love him too. We've totally become family and I just, I just loved our crew. I just loved our crew so much. This is completely not related to Nick Carbone, but I have to share it.
所以唯一真正为我别过电视麦克风的人就是尼克·卡博尼，他还保留着我的特制绑腿。这太贴心了。我太喜欢他了。我也喜欢他。我们完全成了一家人，而且我，我太喜欢我们的剧组了。我太喜欢我们的剧组了。这跟尼克·卡博尼完全没有关系，但我必须分享它。
Jenna wore pantyhose every day. They were in her trailer. The same pantyhose were in my trailer. They were putting my trailer every day starting day one. I never put them on. I never, I refuse to wear pantyhose. I refuse to wear pantyhose. And Jenna one day, I mean, it was years into the office and I remember the day.
珍娜每天都穿连裤袜。它们在她的化妆车里。同样的连裤袜也在我的化妆车里。从第一天开始，它们每天都被放在我的化妆车里。我从来没穿过。我从来没有，我拒绝穿连裤袜。我拒绝穿连裤袜。然后有一天珍娜，我的意思是，那是拍摄《办公室》好几年后了，我记得那一天的情景。
It was years into filming like seasons upon seasons and she looked over at me one day and she was like, you don't have on pantyhose. I was like, oh yeah, they put them in my trailer. I don't wear those things. I'm not wearing pantyhose. And she was like, what the hell? I've been wearing pantyhose for years. I am such a rule follower that it had never occurred to me that I could go rogue and just
那是拍摄好几年之后，经历了一季又一季，她有一天看着我，然后说，你没穿连裤袜。我当时就说，哦，是的，他们把它放在我的化妆车里。我不穿那些东西。我没穿连裤袜。她当时就说，搞什么鬼？我穿了好几年连裤袜了。我是如此遵守规则的人，以至于我从未想过我可以特立独行
not wear the pantyhose. I just didn't put them on. No one said anything. I didn't put them on. No one said anything. I mean, listen, there were times when I didn't dress the bottom half of my body. Well, you need to explain that because it sounds, yeah, yeah, I should let me expand on that.
不穿连裤袜。我只是没有穿上它们。没有人说什么。我没有穿上它们。没有人说什么。我的意思是，听着，有时候我甚至不打扮我的下半身。好吧，你需要解释一下，因为听起来，是的，是的，我应该展开讲讲。
You know, yes, so sometimes if I was only seated behind the reception desk, I only dress the top half of Pam and the bottom half was Uggs and sweatpants. Yes. So I did get a break from the pantyhose, but I never wore them ever. I can't believe that. I just kept shoving them aside. I shoved them aside for like two years and then they just gave up and stopped putting them in my trailer.
你知道，是的，有时候如果我只是坐在接待台后面，我只打扮帕姆的上半身，下半身则是UGG雪地靴和运动裤。是的。所以我确实从连裤袜中解脱出来了，但我从来没有穿过它们。我简直不敢相信。我只是把它们推到一边。我把它们推到一边大约两年，然后他们终于放弃了，不再把它们放在我的化妆车里了。
I used to look so forward to our quote unquote winter episodes because they would give me tights, which were way more comfortable than pantyhose. And then after a while, I had to say, stop putting control top pantyhose in my trailer. I don't want to wear control top pantyhose for 12 hours a day. You and my grandmother, especially after the holidays, this is a sentence that could like set up so many conversations for me with Jenna, but Jenna, you and my grandmother are the only two people I knew for a period of time that wore pantyhose every day. My grandmother wore pantyhose every day of her life.
我曾经非常期待我们的所谓冬季剧集，因为他们会给我紧身裤，那比连裤袜舒服多了。后来过了一段时间，我不得不说，别再把塑形连裤袜放进我的化妆车了。我不想一天 12 小时都穿着塑形连裤袜。你和我奶奶一样，尤其是在假期之后，这句话可以为我和珍娜引发许多对话，但是珍娜，你和我的奶奶是我在一段时间内认识的唯一每天都穿连裤袜的人。我奶奶一生中每天都穿连裤袜。
She was like, she always had on pantyhose. I can't wait to be 75 because I think I'll finally make sense. You're already there. I've been, I've been a 75 year old woman since I was born. Okay, Jenna, I know we're done with Fast Facts, but I have a Kinsey tidbit. Oh, what? This is the episode where we became best friends. Yes.
她就像，她总是穿着连裤袜。我迫不及待地想活到 75 岁，因为我想我终于能活明白了。你已经到了。我一直，我从出生起就是一个 75 岁的老太太。好吧，珍娜，我知道我们讲完了快讯，但我有一个金斯利趣闻。哦，什么？这就是我们成为好朋友的那一集。是的。
Yes, it is. It is. Well, that's kind of a big bit, Angela. That's not a tidbit. That's a big bit. Is that a big bit? Little bit? Oh, yes.
是的，它是。它是。好吧，这算是一个大爆料，安吉拉。这不叫趣闻。这是一个大料。这是一个大料吗？小料？哦，是的。
Did you see what I did there? Did you see what I did there? I see what you did there. Yes. Yes. We should tell this story. So Jenna and I, up until this point in the office, we had that partition between us. We've been speaking over the partition.
你看到我刚才的操作了吗？你看到我刚才的操作了吗？我看到你的操作了。是的。是的。我们应该讲讲这个故事。所以珍娜和我，在《办公室》直到这一刻之前，我们之间都有那个隔板。我们一直透过隔板说话。
Over the partition, but now as we filmed basketball, we were now sitting next to each other on that bench. It was Jenna, me and Phyllis sitting on that bench all day next to each other for two solid days. And a day of filming is about 12 hours. Yeah. 24 solid hours on that bench. And you say, I just kept talking your ear off.
隔板上面，但现在当我们拍摄篮球赛时，我们现在并肩坐在那条长椅上。整整两天，珍娜、我和菲莉丝一整天都并肩坐在那条长椅上。一天的拍摄大约是 12 个小时。是的。那条长椅上整整 24 个小时。然后你说，我一直在喋喋不休地跟你说话。
You would not stop talking to me. Yes. The reason we are best friends is because Angela would not stop speaking to me. Jenna just finally gave up. You wore me down. I wore you down. No, but we told each other our life stories on that bench. We did.
你根本停不下来跟我说话。是的。我们成为好朋友的原因是因为安吉拉根本停不下来跟我说话。珍娜最后终于放弃了。你把我磨垮了。我把你磨垮了。不，但我们在那条长椅上向对方倾诉了我们的人生故事。我们确实说了。
24 hours. It was like the bench of truth. It was the bench of truth. Everything you could possibly want to share. I will never forget. We were leaving one night. We had taped till really late at night. We'd had a long day, and it was our day two.
24 小时。这就好像是真理长椅。这就是真理长椅。所有你想分享的一切。我永远不会忘记。有一天晚上我们要走了。我们录到很晚。我们度过了漫长的一天，那是我们的第二天。
So you and I have now talked for the full 24 hours, and it's late at night, and we had to walk from where the warehouse set was back to our trailers, and it was a little bit of a walk. And we linked arms, arm in arm, and we started doing the Laverne and Shirley song. Shamile, shamile. I remember this. And we were going up and down, and we were like, we're going to do it. I don't know why we were doing this.
所以你和我现在已经聊了整整 24 个小时，而且时间很晚了，我们得从仓库片场走回我们的化妆车，那还有一段路。我们手挽着手，手臂挽着手臂，开始唱起《拉弗恩和雪莉》的歌。拉米勒，拉米勒。我记得这个。我们上下晃动着，然后我们说，我们要上啦。我不知道为什么我们要这么做。
And I don't know why we weren't, because we were giddy. We had lost our minds, because we'd been in that warehouse for 24 hours. Unbeknownst to us, quietly walking behind us was Steve Carell. And we turned around and realized he'd watched us do this whole Laverne and Shirley song and dance, and we started laughing, because we were embarrassed. And he looked at us and smiled, and he said, you guys, no matter what happens with this show, because we were on the chopping block. Always on the chopping block.
我也不知道我们为什么不这么做，因为我们当时太晕头转向了。我们快疯了，因为我们在那个仓库里待了 24 小时。我们不知道的是，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔正静静地跟在我们身后。我们转过身，意识到他看着我们完成了整首歌舞，我们开始笑，因为我们觉得很尴尬。他看着我们，笑了笑，说，你们俩，不管这个节目会发生什么，因为我们当时面临被砍的危险。总是面临被砍的危险。
Always on the chopping block, that first season, for sure. And he was like, no matter what happens with the show, this is what you guys will have from it. And he looked at the two of us, this friendship. And I'll never forget it, because he was right. And you say, this is the episode. You have a photo. This is the moment we became best friends.
第一季肯定总是面临被砍的危险。他说，不管这个节目发生什么，这就是你们俩能从中得到的。他看着我们俩，这份友谊。我永远不会忘记，因为他是对的。你说，这就是这一集。你有一张照片。这就是我们成为好朋友的时刻。
I have a photo of us sitting on that bench from this episode, framed in my office. Aw. Yeah. Lady. That's so sweet. And I have a sense memory of my butt falling asleep. Oh, my butt fell asleep. So many times.
我的办公室里装裱着一张我们在这集中坐在长椅上的照片。啊。是的。女士。太甜了。我有肌肉记忆，记得我的屁股都坐麻了。哦，我的屁股坐麻了。好多次。
My butt fell asleep, and the shoes I was wearing were called SAS. I remember those shoes. Okay, these are the shoes you guys, like, nuns wear. Well, here's the thing you need to know about SAS shoes. They're incredibly comfortable. So if I was going to be a nun on my feet, I get it. But there was someone in my life that loves SAS shoes and wore them almost every day. And that was my grandmother.
我的屁股坐麻了，我当时穿的鞋子叫 SAS。我记得那双鞋。好吧，各位，这些鞋子，就像修女穿的鞋子。好吧，关于 SAS 鞋，你需要知道的是。它们非常舒适。所以如果我要当一个脚踩修女鞋的人，我懂。但我的生活中有一个人非常喜欢 SAS 鞋，几乎每天都穿。那就是我奶奶。
Really? Yes. So when I got those shoes, I called her and I said, grandmother, I'm wearing SAS shoes. And she'll say, oh, you'll love them. You'll love them. All this story is making me think about is getting some SAS shoes. I love a comfortable shoe. Well, I love a comfortable pant.
真的吗？是的。所以当我拿到那双鞋时，我打电话给她，我说，奶奶，我穿着 SAS 鞋。她会说，哦，你会喜欢它们的。你会喜欢它们的。这一切故事让我想到的就是去买几双 SAS 鞋。我喜欢舒服的鞋子。好吧，我喜欢舒服的裤子。
I love a comfortable shoe. I want an elastic waistband. Mm-hmm. We've just established that you've been 75 since birth, so I think we need to get you some SAS shoes. Let's do it. We're going to go to a break. I'm going to start googling.
我喜欢舒服的鞋子。我想要松紧腰带。嗯-hmm。我们刚刚确定你从出生起就已经 75 岁了，所以我觉得我们得给你弄几双 SAS 鞋。干吧。我们要去休息一下。我要开始谷歌搜索了。
Let's start at the beginning of this episode. Michael enters the office and starts asking if people are ready for the big game. Oh, this is early days of the office. Michael was super cringy. He was. Oh, my God. Look, first of all, he, like, just accosts you. He just walks up and swats you with a newspaper.
让我们从这一集的开头开始。迈克尔走进办公室，开始询问大家是否准备好迎接那场大战。哦，这是《办公室》的早期。迈克尔超级尴尬。他是的。哦，天哪。听着，首先，他，就像，直接纠缠你。他径直走过来，用报纸拍打你。
He's like, bam, whack. He does. Yeah. He would come up to my desk and I would flinch. Yeah. First, I want to say, and it is my personal opinion, that basketball is one of the best episodes we ever did. Really?
他就像，砰，打。他确实这么做了。是的。他会走到我的桌子前，我会畏缩。是的，首先我想说，这是我个人的看法，篮球赛是我们拍过的最好的剧集之一。真的吗？
I absolutely love it. I think it is so good. One of my favorite scenes in this episode is the one where Dwight follows Michael into his office and tries to convince him that he should be part of the basketball team. And they get in this exchange that is so wonderful. Michael says, no, not after what happened at that pickup game. And then Dwight is like, I apologized for that. And he's like, I vouched for you.
我绝对喜欢它。我觉得它太棒了。这一集中我最喜欢的场景之一是德怀特跟着迈克尔进他的办公室，试图说服他自己应该成为篮球队的一员。他们展开了如此精彩的对话。迈克尔说，不，在上次那场野球赛发生那种事之后不行。然后德怀特说，我为那件事道过歉了。然后他说，我为你担保了。
I vouched for you in front of Todd Packer. Now here's the amazing thing about this show is that we've never met Todd Packer. He's only been mentioned one other time, which is in the pilot, when he calls in on speaker phone while Michael is having a meeting with Jan, he says a bunch of inappropriate stuff, and Michael just shuts him off the speaker phone. But you can tell in that phone call, Michael covets this guy. He loves this man. He's the coolest guy.
我在托德·帕克面前为你担保了。现在关于这个节目最神奇的事情是，我们从未见过托德·帕克。他只被提及过一次，那是在试播集中，当迈克尔正与简开会时，他通过免提电话打进来，他说了一堆不合适的话，迈克尔直接挂断了免提电话。但你可以从那个电话中看出，迈克尔很嫉妒这家伙。他爱这个男人。他是最酷的家伙。
We are not going to meet Todd Packer. I looked it up. Do you know when we finally meet him? Season two, sexual harassment episode. Oh, that's perfect. Which, yes, I know. But that's like far. Yeah.
我们不会见到托德·帕克的。我查过了。你知道我们什么时候最终见到他吗？第二季，性骚扰那一集。哦，那太完美了。是的，我知道。但这有点远。是的。
Like that's a while. Well, I do love this. And I feel like Greg Daniels was so great about this. And with our writer's room is we just jumped in the middle of these people's lives. You know, we don't tell backstory and the audience just has to catch up. And I love that. Yeah. I love all these little nuggets.
就像那需要一段时间。好吧，我真的很喜欢这个。我觉得格雷格·丹尼尔斯在这方面太棒了。还有我们的编剧室，我们只是直接跳进了这些人生活的中间。你知道，我们不讲背景故事，观众只能自己跟上。我喜欢这样。是的。我喜欢所有这些小彩蛋。
And this episode in particular has a lot of little nuggets. You see these dynamics that then play out years later. I love, and I don't want to jump too far ahead, but like Dwight and Angela's power struggle, it's the first time you see it is in this episode. Yes. All right. So we'll play that clip. I think I should be on the team.
特别是这一集有很多小彩蛋。你看到了这些后来几年才会爆发的动态。我喜欢，我不想剧透太多，但比如德怀特和安吉拉的权力斗争，你第一次看到它就是在这集中。是的。好吧。所以我们来播放那个片段。我觉得我应该进球队。
No. And that's not me being mean Dwight. That is based on your past behavior. Oh, please. I let him come to my pickup game. I apologize for that. I vouch for you. I vouch for you in front of Todd Packard, Dwight.
不。这不是我针对你，德怀特。这是根据你过去的行为决定的。哦，拜托。我让他去参加我的野球赛。我为那件事道过歉了。我为你担保了。我在托德·帕克面前为你担保了，德怀特。
I love in this little scene when Rain looks to the camera, like he has a few, like, looks to the camera that are just great. And I feel like this was really fun for all of us, this documentary kind of genre, because we did get to do that. And even in years later, I have jobs and every once in a while, a director would say, Angela, you just looked at camera. I can't look at camera. I do it still too.
我喜欢这个小场景里雷恩看着镜头的时候，他有几次看向镜头的眼神简直太棒了。我觉得这对我我们所有人来说都很有趣，这种伪纪录片式的类型，因为我们确实做到了。甚至在多年后，我有工作时，偶尔会有导演说，安吉拉，你刚才看镜头了。我不能看镜头。我到现在还是会这样。
And I'm like, oh, crap, sorry. For nine years, I would check in with the camera. It's so true. The camera was a character. Yeah. It was another person that we could relate to the documentarian, quote unquote. And so we were encouraged to make them a part of the conversation. Yeah.
然后我就想，哦，该死，对不起。连续九年，我都会跟镜头核对。太真实了。镜头是一个角色。是的。这是另一个人，我们可以与所谓的纪录片制作者产生共鸣。所以我们被鼓励让他们成为对话的一部分。是的。
I know. And then it's weird to then take other jobs where you're like, oh, right, right. You're not actually filming me. Yeah. Back to pretending like this is not, you're not in the room. Exactly. Exactly. Okay.
我知道。然后接其他工作会觉得很奇怪，你会想，哦，对，对。你其实并没有在拍我。是的。回到假装这不是在拍，你不在房间里。完全正确。完全正确。好吧。
I have a note card. And this is sort of like a personal gripe, Jenna. Okay. Oh, you have a gripe. I know. You love a gripe. I live for a gripe. Okay.
我有一张记事卡。这有点像个人的牢骚，珍娜。好吧。哦，你有牢骚。我知道。你喜欢发牢骚。我为发牢骚而活。好吧。
So in this episode, I wear a bun that's like a mid bun. It's like, it's in the middle of the back of my head. And who wants bobby pins in the middle of the back of their head all day, like 12 hour days. So I look at women who wear buns differently now. Because of the number of buns your character had. Yes. Well, I got a lot of buns. I had a lot of buns, but I had such a bad headache by the end of basketball.
所以在这一集中，我梳了一个中等高度的发髻。它就像，它在我的后脑勺中间。谁整天想在后脑勺中间别满发夹，像12个小时的工作日。所以我现在对梳发髻的女性看法不同了。因为你的角色梳发髻的次数。是的。好吧，我梳了很多发髻。我有很多发髻，但在篮球赛结束时我头痛得要命。
So I think if you look at me and I have a grumpy like face, it's because I'm from your bun for five days in a row. And I remember going to the hair and makeup trailer after this episode and being like, can we please like take a break from a bun? I can't. That hurts. How do women, I don't understand how women who wear buns every day aren't grumpy every day.
所以我想如果你看着我，我有一张暴躁的脸，那是因为我连续五天顶着你的发髻。我记得在这一集之后去了发型和化妆车，说，我们能不能请假不梳发髻？我受不了了。这太疼了。女人们怎么，我不明白那些每天梳发髻的女人怎么能每天都不暴躁。
Maybe they are. Maybe they haven't put it together though. So please out there, if you are perpetually grumpy and have a bun, we just want to call your attention to the fact that that might be a cause effect there. Break the bun. Break the bun. Hashtag break the bun. Hashtag break the bun.
也许她们是暴躁的。不过也许她们还没把这联系起来。所以请各位，如果你总是暴躁并且梳着发髻，我们只想引起你的注意，那可能是因果关系。打破发髻。打破发髻。话题：打破发髻。话题：打破发髻。
Another great scene is when Michael leads Ryan down into the warehouse. There's that great quote. He's managing by walking around. Oh, yes. That would be in his book, How I Manage. Michael Scott's book, How I Manage. Here's a little trivia. It's the first time we go down into the warehouse.
另一个伟大的场景是迈克尔带着雷恩下到仓库。有一个很棒的名言。他在通过四处走动来进行管理。哦，是的。那会写在他的书里，《我是如何管理的》。迈克尔·斯科特的书，《我是如何管理的》。这里有一个小冷知识。这是我们第一次下到仓库。
Yeah. Yeah. In this episode, we were filming in Culver City. So those stairs actually were real. They actually existed. We filmed in an actual building that was an old company. These offices were on the second floor of that building too. That's right.
是的。是的。在这集中，我们在卡尔尔城拍摄。所以那些楼梯其实是真的。它们确实存在。我们在一个真正属于一家老公司的建筑里拍摄。这些办公室也在该建筑的二楼。没错。
And so you go down the stairs to the warehouse, but in years later, they recreated the whole office in a different location on a soundstage. And those stairs still existed, but they led nowhere. It was a tiny closet about three feet wide, and you would hide in the tiny closet. And then on cue, you would open the door and walk out. So there were many times when you would either be up there by yourself in the tiny closet or you'd be up there, like one time I was up there with Oscar and Kevin. And there's not a lot of space up there.
所以你走楼梯下到仓库，但在几年后，他们在另一个地方的摄影棚里重建了整个办公室。而那些楼梯依然存在，但它们通往虚无。那是一个大约三英尺宽的小壁橱，你会藏在那个小壁橱里。然后在听到暗号时，你打开门走出去。所以有很多次，你要么自己一个人待在那上面的小壁橱里，要么你会在那上面，比如有一次我和奥斯卡和凯文一起在那上面。上面没有多少空间。
No. And we just tucked in that little closet for about 20 minutes until our characters came in the scene. But this was where we were really using this real warehouse and this real space. And there are some shots outside where you can tell that it's not the same place as seasons later. I know. I know.
没有。我们只是挤在那个小壁橱里大约 20 分钟，直到我们的角色进入场景。但这就是我们真正使用这个真实仓库和真实空间的地方。外面有一些镜头你可以看出它和几年后不是同一个地方。我知道。我知道。
There's some things they couldn't cover. That's fun for the super nerd. Okay. Well, I think we should play this clip of Michael introducing Ryan to Craig Robinson, who plays Daryl, the manager of the warehouse. This is one of my favorite introductions of a character on the office because the sort of journey that his name takes with Michael of how Michael comes up with this nickname for him is so ridiculous.
有些东西他们无法掩盖。这对超级剧迷来说很有趣。好吧。嗯，我觉得我们应该播放迈克尔向克雷格·罗宾逊介绍雷恩的片段，克雷格饰演仓库经理达里尔。这是《办公室》中我最喜欢的角色介绍之一，因为他的名字在迈克尔口中经历的奇妙旅程，即迈克尔是如何为他起这个昵称的，实在是太荒谬了。
And Craig Robinson does such a great job in the scene of just throwing it away. He's so amazing. All right. We should watch it. We'll discuss. And here we have Mitha Rajah's neighborhood. Come on over here. Hey, this is Ryan.
而且克雷格·罗宾逊在这个场景中表现得非常出色，轻描淡写。他太棒了。好了。我们应该看一下。我们讨论一下。这里是米塔·拉贾的街区。过来这里。嘿，这是雷恩。
He's temping upstairs. What's up? And it's the far man, Mitha Rajah's. It's not my real name. No. It's Daryl. Daryl is Mitha Rajah's. Daryl Rajah's.
他在楼上做临时工。最近怎么样？还有远方人，米塔·拉贾斯。这不是我的真名。不。是达里尔。达里尔是米塔·拉贾斯。达里尔·拉贾斯。
They're filming. And then Regis, then Reg, then Rajah, then Mitha Rajah's. What is the amazing history? How many years has Michael been calling him by not his name? I know. Of Daryl. I know. It's so good.
他们在拍。然后里吉斯，然后雷格，然后拉贾，然后米塔·拉贾斯。这背后的历史有多神奇？迈克尔用错名字叫他多少年了？我知道。达里尔的。我知道。太搞笑了。
It's so good. And you so see in Michael's brain how he got there. Oh, total sense. Daryl Philbin. Philbin. Oh, Regis Philbin. Reg. Raj.
太搞笑了。你完全能看出迈克尔的大脑是怎么得出这个结论的。哦，完全说得通。达里尔·菲尔宾。菲尔宾。哦，里吉斯·菲尔宾。雷格。拉杰。
Raj. Mr. Rajah. Yes, it totally works. And I have to wonder, this is like when I would love to do a dial-in phone call, but to call Mike Scherr, because Mike Scherr was one of our writers on the show, and he is married to J.J. Philbin. J.J.
拉杰。拉贾先生。是的，完全行得通。我不得不纳闷，这就像是我很想打个电话的时候，去打电话给迈克尔·舍尔，因为迈克尔·舍尔是我们剧组的编剧之一，他娶了 J.J. 菲尔宾。J.J.
Philbin's dad is Regis. And I know Greg had told me that some of the people's names were formations of different people who had family and stuff on the show. Well, you know, Jim Helpert is Greg's friend, Jim Helpert. Helpert. Yes. He was his first and last name, and Greg asked him permission to use his name, and the guy was like, oh, yeah, sure, it's no big deal.
菲尔宾的爸爸是里吉斯。我知道格雷格曾告诉我，有些人的名字是剧组中拥有家人等各种背景的不同人的组合。好吧，你知道的，吉姆·霍尔珀特是格雷格的朋友，吉姆·霍尔珀特。霍尔珀特。是的。他用了他的名和姓，格雷格征求了他使用这个名字的许可，这家伙就说，哦，好吧，没问题，这没什么大不了的。
He came to set one day. I was like, yeah, it's no big deal. Nine years later, it was kind of a big deal, and he would call places and be like, Jim Helpert. And he'd be like, oh, yeah, okay. Yeah, roll. Okay, right. I know.
他有一天来到片场。我当时想，是的，这没什么大不了的。九年之后，这就成了一件大事，他会打电话去某些地方说，吉姆·霍尔珀特。然后对方会说，哦，好吧，好的。是的，走。好吧，对。我知道。
And Phyllis Lappin. Phyllis's last name Lappin. Lappin is the last name of a friend of Greg's as well. And so I have to think that Daryl Philbin was maybe Mike Scherr's nod to his father-in-law. His wife's side of the family, but then became this great runner for Michael Scott, which is so great. It's so good. All right.
还有菲莉丝·拉宾。菲莉丝的姓拉宾。拉宾也是格雷格一个朋友的姓氏。所以我不得不认为达里尔·菲尔宾可能是迈克尔·舍尔向他的岳父致敬。他妻子那边的家庭，但后来成了迈克尔·斯科特的一个很棒的梗，这真的很棒。太棒了。好吧。
Here we go. We're moving on, Jenna. We're moving on. What happens next? Well, they go back up in the office, right? Yes. They go back to work. Right.
我们继续，珍娜。我们继续。接下来发生什么？好吧，他们回到办公室了，对吧？是的。他们回去工作了。没错。
That's when he says, okay, who's starting? Stanley, of course. Yeah. And why, of course. Yeah. Leslie David Baker's like, excuse me, like kind of look he gives him is so perfect. Now, if I remember correctly, Leslie was truly a horrible basketball player. Yes.
就在那时他说，好吧，谁首发？当然是斯坦利。是的。为什么当然是他。是的。莱斯利·大卫·贝克那种“excuse me”的表情太完美了。现在，如果我没记错的话，莱斯利其实是个糟糕的篮球运动员。是的。
Leslie was like, oh, I don't play sports. Yeah. Not a sports guy. That was really perfect. And Phyllis was so excited. She wanted to be on the team in real life. I'm talking Phyllis in real life was like so excited to be part of the basketball team. Phyllis and her youth was a burlesque dancer.
莱斯利就像，哦，我不做运动。是的。不是一个运动男。那真的太完美了。菲莉丝超级兴奋。她在现实生活中就想进球队。我说的是现实生活中的菲莉丝，超级兴奋能成为篮球队的一员。菲莉丝年轻时是个滑稽杂耍舞者。
This is true. And she has quite the moves. And there is a tiny clip as they warm up before the game where she's moving her arms and stuff. But her warm up seemed very burlesque. Yeah, dance-like. But she was, there's a few times throughout the game when she finally gets to participate and you see her smile.
这是真的。她很有舞技。在比赛前的热身中有一个小片段，她晃动着手臂之类的。但她的热身看起来非常像滑稽杂耍。是的，很有舞蹈感。但在比赛中，当她终于能够参与时，有几次你看到她笑了。
And that's genuine. Like Phyllis was like, I'm in the game, I'm so excited. I do have to say before we get into the game part, one thing is that you see my character looking through the supply closet and I'm looking for the first aid kit. And I'm like, where is the first aid kit? And then Dwight doesn't even look around, he just holds it up, right? And I have this line that to me is kind of like that Todd Packer line in the first part of the episode that is so loaded with information.
那是真心的。就像菲莉丝在说，我在比赛中，我太兴奋了。在我进入比赛部分之前我必须说，有一件事是你看到我的角色在储物柜里找东西，我在找急救箱。我说，急救箱在哪里？然后德怀特甚至不看周围，他直接把它举起来了，对吧？我有句台词，对我和这一集第一部分的那个托德·帕克台词一样，包含着大量的信息。
Yes. Because I say, how many times do I have to tell you I'm the safety officer, not you? Yes. It's like, how many times has Dwight tried to usurp Angela's power? How many times has he taken that first aid kit and tried to be safety officer? What is their backstory there? I would love to know. I love that we don't know, we just know that they are adversarial in this moment and that
是的。因为我说，我得跟你说多少次我是安全员，不是你？是的。这就好像，德怀特试图篡夺安吉拉的权力有多少次了？他拿过那个急救箱并试图当安全员多少次了？他们之间有什么背景故事？我很想知道。我喜欢我们不知道，我们只知道他们在这一刻是对立的，而且
they both love power and control. Later in season two in the episode email surveillance, we will learn that Dwight and Angela are in a relationship. Yes. So we actually got a lot of comments about this. There were a lot of people who asked, were Dwight and Angela already in a relationship at this point? I don't think they're in a relationship yet.
他们都热爱权力和控制。在第二季的《电子邮件监控》一集中，我们将了解到德怀特和安吉拉正在恋爱。是的。所以我们实际上收到了很多关于这点的评论。有很多人问，德怀特和安吉拉在这个时候就已经在恋爱了吗？我觉得他们当时还没恋爱。
I think it's the beginning. I think it's the beginning. I think, you know, they both kind of, they like each other, but they also are annoyed by each other. So they have this weird, like Yin and Yang pull and I think it's the beginning. I feel like the more they gave that bit to you guys to play, then it gave them the idea to write this as some weird twisted romance. Yes.
我觉得那是开始。我觉得那是开始。我觉得，你知道，他们俩都有点，他们喜欢对方，但也对彼此感到恼火。所以他们有一种奇怪的阴阳吸引力，我觉得那是开始。我觉得他们把那个桥段交给你们演得越多，就越给他们灵感，把这写成某种奇怪扭曲的浪漫史。是的。
And when we found out we were a couple was at the table read. And that happened a lot for us on this show. Yes. Is that the writers would come up with things and we would sit down at lunch all together around a table. Once a week. Once a week and read a new script, usually on Wednesday, we would read a new script and we would, they would be handing them to us as we walked in the room.
当我们发现我们是一对时，是在围读剧本的时候。这在我们的剧组经常发生。是的。就是编剧们会想出一些点子，然后我们大家每周一起围坐在一张桌子旁吃午饭。一周一次。一周一次，读一个新剧本，通常在周三，我们会读一个新剧本，然后他们会在我们走进房间时把剧本递给我们。
Sometimes the paper was hot. Yes. I remember. And we would cold read these out loud. And a lot of times we discovered information as we read them. And that was definitely one of them when we see the Birkenstocks moving in the dollhouse in the backyard. We were like, Oh my God.
有时纸还是热的。是的。我记得。我们会大声朗读这些剧本。很多时候，我们是在朗读的过程中才发现这些信息的。这绝对是其中之一，当我们看到勃肯鞋在后院的娃娃屋里移动时。我们当时就想，哦，天哪。
I remember I found out Pam was pregnant during a table read and being like a fan of the show, I would want information like anyone else. Yeah. I wouldn't get it early, but I would still have to wait for that table read moment to find out. Yeah. Like we weren't, they wouldn't say, Okay, this season, here are the five things that are going to happen to your character.
我记得是在一次围读剧本时发现帕姆怀孕的，作为这部剧的粉丝，我会像任何人一样想要了解信息。是的。我不会提前知道，但我仍然得等到那个围读剧本的时刻去发现。是的。就像我们不是，他们不会说，好吧，这一季，这里有五件将要在你角色身上发生的事情。
No. No, you had to wait for each week to see how the drama unfolded. Yeah. It was really fun. Oh, I have to tell the story. So, okay. So, you know, as Michael picks his team, we then see a montage of all of us throwing things into the trash can.
不。不，你得一周一周地等待，看看剧情是如何展开的。是的。真的很有趣。哦，我必须讲这个故事。所以，好吧。所以，你知道，当迈克尔挑选他的队伍时，我们接着看到一个蒙太奇，展示了我们所有人把东西扔进垃圾桶。
It starts with Dwight. He tries to make a shot. He misses. Dwight's face was so cute when he like did his fingers like, I miss him so close and he got to be on the team when he was so happy. And then of course, Stanley misses, Oscar gets it in no problem, you know, and people go around making these baskets. Well, we did B roll.
从德怀特开始。他试图投篮。他没进。德怀特当时的表情太可爱了，他做着手指的手势仿佛在说，我差一点就进了，他能进球队时他是那么高兴。然后当然，斯坦利没进，奥斯卡轻而易举地进了，你知道，大家轮流投篮。好吧，我们拍了B卷。
We had always had a camera and we had B camera on the show and the B camera would pick up all these little moments happening in the background. And so they had all of us toss things kind of nonchalantly into our, our desk trash can. And I made mine on the first try and I made like three in a row and they didn't even include it because they're like, it just doesn't track that you would, that Angela would like be like a ringer or anything. And of course, Brian made his and that is something you guys should know is that where our trailers were, our trailers are where you hang out between scenes, right?
我们一直有摄像机，我们在剧中有B机，B机会捕捉到背景中发生的这些小瞬间。所以他们让我们所有人漫不经心地把东西扔进我们的办公桌垃圾桶里。我第一次尝试就投中了，我连续投中了三个，他们甚至都没把它剪进去，因为他们觉得，安吉拉是个高手或者别的什么，这根本不符合人设。当然，布莱恩投中了，你们应该知道的一件事是，我们的化妆车在哪里，我们的化妆车就是我们在场景之间闲逛的地方，对吧？
Where our trailers were, they put up a basketball hoop and we would play horse in between scenes if we had a break. We'd all go out there and play horse and I have a photo of us and Brian was an amazing shooter. Brian's an amazing athlete. He's a great athlete. Great golfer. So the cast knew this.
在我们的化妆车旁边，他们竖起了一个篮球架，如果我们有休息时间，我们会在场景之间玩马术投篮游戏。我们都会去那里玩马术投篮，我有一张我们的照片，布莱恩是一个惊人的投篮手。布莱恩是一个惊人的运动员。他是一个伟大的运动员。伟大的高尔夫球手。所以剧组都知道这一点。
And so when this episode came about, we all knew what a great shooter he was. And but the writers and Greg didn't know. They did not know. And so in between scenes, he would grab a basketball and just start shooting. And he like was just sinking them left and right. And it became a thing at the end of the episode. So you'll see him, he make, they just let the camera roll. He makes one shot, gets it in from kind of close to the three point line.
所以当这一集出现时，我们都知道他是一个多么伟大的投篮手。但是编剧和格雷格并不知道。他们不知道。所以在场景之间，他会抓起一个篮球开始投篮。他就这样左一个右一个地把球投进。这成了这一集结尾的一个桥段。所以你会看到他投进，他们只是让摄像机开着。他从接近三分线的地方投中了一个。
But then he keeps taking a step back, step back. So by the end, he's well at like three point range. And he made, I think it was 13 or 14 in a row. And they got it. We show three or four, I think. Yeah. But he actually made, I think it was 14. And we all were there with like pins and needles.
但他一直在往后退，往后退。所以到最后，他完全在三分线范围内。我记得他连续投中了 13 或 14 个。他们拍下来了。我们展示了三四个，我想。是的。但他实际上投中了，我想是 14 个。我们所有人都提心吊胆地站在那里。
And when he missed the 15th one, we all cheered. It was like so cool. Okay. Should we take a quick break? I think we should. Should we also talk about the Jim Pam part of this episode? Yes. Yes.
当他投失第 15 个球时，我们都欢呼了。感觉太酷了。好吧。我们要不要快速休息一下？我觉得我们应该。我们是不是也应该聊聊这一集里吉姆和帕姆的部分？是的。是的。
Because they have such an awkward flirty scene that is so funny to me. First of all, I love that the, the subject of their flirt is the mall or wave runners. This was so relatable to me because I have family that live in like Northern Texas. And on the weekend, you go to the lake and you go to the mall. Yes. Exactly. These are the choices. Jim is going to go to the mall for the weekend if he doesn't have to work.
因为他们有一场非常尴尬的调情戏，我觉得太搞笑了。首先，我喜欢他们调情的主题是商场或水上摩托艇。这对我来说太有共鸣了，因为我有亲戚住在德克萨斯州北部。周末的时候，你去湖边，然后你去商场。是的。没错。这些都是选择。吉姆如果不工作，周末就要去商场。
The outlets. The outlets. The outlet mall. Yeah. And then Pam said that if Roy wins, they're going to take the wave runners up to the lake. Yeah. I love it.
奥特莱斯。奥特莱斯。奥特莱斯商场。是的。然后帕姆说如果罗伊赢了，他们要把水上摩托艇开到湖上去。是的。我太喜欢了。
And Jim says, well, I think Roy is going to be working. So I think you're going to be coming to the mall with me, you know, just if you want to save big on brand names. Super cute. But I have to say that whole wave runner backstory, that was based on a backstory that I wrote about Pam and Roy that ended up making it into the show in this very subtle way. So I remember trying to justify just as myself, why is Pam still engaged to Roy after three years?
吉姆说，嗯，我觉得罗伊要工作。所以我觉得你要跟我去商场了，你知道的，如果你想在名牌上省大钱的话。超级可爱。但我必须说，整个水上摩托艇的背景故事，是基于我为帕姆和罗伊写的一个背景故事，最后以这种非常微妙的方式呈现在剧中。所以我还记得试图证明，仅仅作为我自己，为什么帕姆在三年后仍然和罗伊订婚？
Cause in this episode, you find out like they've been engaged for three years. Yes. Her toaster oven is broken. Her toaster oven. She's sad. It's a reminder. Her engagement party is broken. Yeah.
因为在这一集中，你发现他们已经订婚三年了。是的。她的烤面包机坏了。她的烤面包机。她很难过。这是一个提醒。她的订婚派对坏了。是的。
They're still not married. Why? Why are they not married yet? It's been three years. What is the reason? In my head, I came up with the reason that they had been saving money for the wedding. Wait, wait, wait, wait. I have to pause. Yes.
他们还是没结婚。为什么？他们为什么还不结婚？已经三年了。原因是什么？在我脑海里，我想出了一个理由，那就是他们一直在为婚礼攒钱。等等，等等，等等，等等。我得暂停一下。是的。
I love this about Jenna so much, you guys. This is her actor prep. This is my actor prep. She did this solely for herself. No one asked me to do it. No one asked her to do it. I wrote it in essay form. Again, Jenna, first of her name, keeper of the notes.
各位，我太喜欢珍娜这一点了。这是她的演员准备工作。这是我的演员准备工作。她完全是为自己做的这件事。没有人要求我这么做。没有人要求她这么做。我是以论文的形式写的。再说一次，珍娜，她的名字的首位，笔记的守护者。
I would love to find this document. It was my Pam document. Oh my God. All these little things I made up. Oh my God. You have to find it. Okay, so go. So what was your backstory for yourself?
我很想找到这份文件。那是我的帕姆文件。哦，天哪。所有这些我编出来的小事情。哦，天哪。你必须找到它。好吧，继续。那你给自己的背景故事是什么？
Okay, so my backstory was that they had been saving money for the wedding and about a year into their engagement without telling Pam, Roy spent the money on a pair of wave runners with his brother. This is perfect, Jenna. Yeah. This is perfect. And he, you know, so he and his brother bought these pair of wave runners with their wedding money.
好吧，我的背景故事是他们一直在为婚礼攒钱，大约在订婚一年后，帕姆不知情的情况下，罗伊和他的兄弟把这笔钱花在了一对水上摩托艇上。这太完美了，珍娜。是的。这太完美了。而且他，你知道，所以他和他的兄弟用他们办婚礼的钱买了一对水上摩托艇。
But, you know, Roy was like, we're going to have so much fun with these. So it broke Pam's heart. What an ass. What an ass. And I told Greg this story just bantering with him and he was like, oh my gosh, I love that. We got to put that in. We got to put that in the wave runners.
但是，你知道，罗伊当时说，我们用这些会玩得很开心。所以这伤透了帕姆的心。真是个混蛋。真是个混蛋。我把这个故事随口讲给格雷格听，他当时就说，哦天哪，我太喜欢了。我们得把它加进去。我们得把水上摩托艇加进去。
Yeah. In the wave runners. That is so good. I love that. I love, you know, I feel like as I talked to some of our cast members about our time on the show, we all had moments where we, we gave ourselves a little backstory like that. And obviously we won't get into it here.
是的。水上摩托艇。这太棒了。我喜欢这个。我喜欢，你知道，我觉得当我跟我们的一些演员聊起我们在剧中的时光时，我们都有过这样的时刻，我们为自己设定了一个这样的小背景故事。当然我们不会在这里深入探讨。
Mine was sprinkles. You invented sprinkles. I did. But I did not know you did that about the wave runners. And that is absolutely what Roy would have done. Yeah. And we were going to spend that money. We were going to spend on the wedding.
我的是洒水装置。你发明了洒水装置。我发明了。但我不知道你关于水上摩托艇是这么想的。这绝对是罗伊会做的事。是的。我们本来要花那笔钱的。我们本来要花在婚礼上的。
I got a really good deal on wave runners. Yeah. I'm surprised there were some wave runners. Oh my God. That's amazing. What Pam's always wanted. And I have to say, this is a funny thing. David Denman and I really hit it off.
我买水上摩托艇谈到了一个非常好的价格。是的。我很惊讶竟然有水上摩托艇。哦，天哪。太神奇了。帕姆一直想要的东西。我必须说，这是一件很有趣的事。大卫·丹曼和我真的很合得来。
Yeah, you did. We are good friends in real life. We especially hit it off in this episode. And it was weird because I think I had spent a lot of time talking to John Krasinski between scenes and now I was talking to David Denman. And John was like, hey, where's my chair buddy? My friend go. But he became a really, really good friend of mine outside of the office.
是的，你们合得来。我们在现实生活中是好朋友。我们在这一集中尤其合得来。这很奇怪，因为我觉得我在场景之间花了很多时间跟约翰·卡拉辛斯基聊天，现在我在跟大卫·丹曼聊天。约翰就说，嘿，我的椅子伙伴去哪儿了？我的朋友去哪儿了。但他成了我在《办公室》之外一个非常非常好的朋友。
And I think it was, I think it's probably a weird thing for people to imagine that one of my best connections on the show was with David Denman, who played my jerk boyfriend Roy. I'm sure. Your jerk boyfriend. I'm sure right now, if you guys went out for lunch and you and him walked in, people would be like, why are you with Roy? It's so true.
我觉得这，对于人们来说可能很难想象，我在剧中最好的联系之一竟然是大卫·丹曼，他扮演了我那个混蛋男友罗伊。我确信。你那个混蛋男友。我敢肯定现在你们要是出去吃午饭，你和他走进去，人们会问，你为什么跟罗伊在一起？太真实了。
Where's Jim? I know. I had lunch with Rainn Wilson and people lost their minds. We were like, oh my God, by Angela. So next up, everyone goes down to the warehouse for the big basketball game. I feel like we should say from a production standpoint, we spent two days down in the warehouse playing basketball. That's right.
吉姆在哪？我知道。我和雷恩·威尔逊吃过午饭，大家简直疯狂了。我们当时想，哦天哪，安吉拉。接下来，所有人都要去仓库进行那场盛大的篮球赛。我觉得我们应该从制作的角度说明一下，我们在仓库里打篮球花了两天时间。没错。
And there was a lot of the guys just playing basketball and they filmed them to get like random shots. Footage. Right. But then there were all of these scripted moments that they had to get. Right. And make the game make sense. Yes.
而且很多小伙子们就在那儿打篮球，他们拍了很多随意的镜头。素材。对。但其中也有很多必须拍到的剧本安排的时刻。没错。还要让这场比赛说得通。是的。
Exactly. Can we speak about some highlights from the basketball game? Let's do it. Right. Rainn's crazy nose guard. Oh my God. You know, I knew a guy in high school, Ken, he had to wear one. They're like, they're special.
没错。我们能聊聊篮球比赛中的一些精彩片段吗？来吧。没错。雷恩那疯狂的鼻梁护具。哦天哪。你知道，我在高中时认识一个叫肯的家伙，他必须戴那个。它们挺那啥的，挺特别的。
I guess this was Greg's idea. He wanted him to wear this nose guard. But you know what I love? We never mention it. Nope. We don't know why he's wearing it. Nope. Was he injured once or was he just afraid of injury?
我想这是格雷格的主意。他想让雷恩戴这个鼻梁护具。但你知道我最喜欢的是什么吗？我们从来没提过它。没错。我们不知道他为什么戴着它。没错。他是曾经受过伤，还是只是害怕受伤？
We don't know. We don't know. But of course he would wear it. When Rainn takes his shirt off to be skins. By the way, Rainn, I think loves taking his shirt off. He loves the shock value of his white pasty body. He liked to stick his belly out, like pad it, like look at it. Speaking of Rainn taking off his t-shirt, I have a note card about that shirt that Dwight
我们不知道。我们不知道。但当然啦，他肯定会戴。当雷恩脱掉衬衫赤膊上阵时。顺便说一句，我觉得雷恩非常喜欢脱掉衬衫。他喜欢自己苍白臃肿的身体带来的视觉冲击。他喜欢把肚子挺出来，拍一拍，就像在审视它一样。说起雷恩脱T恤的事，我有一张关于雷恩在篮球赛中穿的那件衬衫的卡片笔记
wears in the basketball game. All right. Now, this was really popular. I saw people commenting on this online when I looked back at the episode. All right. So Dwight is wearing a Japanese anime t-shirt in this game and it's of Koninkotaka. All right. Yes.
。好了。这个当时真的很火。我回看这一集时，看到网上有人在评论这个。好的。所以在这场比赛中，德怀特穿着一件日本动漫T恤，上面印的是绀野木孝（Koninkotaka）。好的。是的。
You're like, all right. You're looking at me like, did you say that right? Here's the thing. I'm not sure. Someone Google it. Koninkotaka. It comes back in Hot Girl. It does?
你当时就像是，好吧。你看着我的眼神就像在问，我刚才说对了吗？事情是这样的。我也不太确定。谁去谷歌一下吧。绀野木孝。这梗在《辣妹》那一集又出现了。真的吗？
Yes. This is a Dwight Deleted. Okay. It's a Dwight Deleted scene. But as you know, I found all the Deleted scenes on probably some illegal site online. And now the- Because you still don't have a DVD player? I don't.
是的。这是德怀特的被删片段。好吧。这是德怀特的被删片段。但如你所知，我大概是在网上某个非法网站上找到了所有被删片段。现在-因为你还是没有DVD播放器？我没有。
And now the cops are going to come for me. Do they come for you? Anyway, I'm such a rule follower. I'm like, oh no. Anyway. You're a rule follower, but you refuse to wear your pantyhose. So which one is it, Angela? Okay, fine.
现在警察要来抓我了。他们会来抓你吗？总之，我是一个绝对遵守规则的人。我想，哦不。不管怎样。你是个遵守规则的人，但你拒绝穿连裤袜。所以到底哪个才是真的，安吉拉？好吧，好吧。
Do you follow the rules or do you break the rules? All right. I follow the police rules. Okay. But I'm going to put what I want on my body. Oh! Oh! Snap!
你到底是遵守规则还是打破规则？好吧。我遵守警察制定的规则。好吧。但我会在我自己的身体上穿我想穿的衣服。哦！哦！太绝了！
Angela! Okay. Anyway, here we go. So, okay. Listen, in this Dwight Deleted scene in Hot Girl, and I'll talk about it here. So listen, guys, when you get to Hot Girl, just know I talked about it, okay? Yeah, we're not going to talk about this again. All right?
安吉拉！好吧。不管怎样，我们继续。所以，好吧。听着，在《辣妹》那一集的德怀特被删片段里，我在这里聊聊它。所以听着，伙计们，当你们看到《辣妹》那一集时，只要知道我聊过这个就行了，好吗？是的，我们不会再讨论这个了。好吗？
You're getting a- you're getting a Kinsey tidbit about Hot Girl a little early. Yeah. But it's because- Because it's tied in. Yes, it's because I love that our writers kept doing these callbacks, even if you didn't get to see him as the viewer. That was part of Dwight's character. So this t-shirt that he wore in basketball comes back in Hot Girl as a reference.
你会提前听到一点关于《辣妹》的吉尼斯（金西）内幕消息。是的。但这是因为-因为它们是连在一起的。是的，因为我喜欢我们的编剧一直坚持做这些前后呼应，哪怕观众在正片里根本看不到。那是德怀特性格的一部分。所以他在这场篮球赛里穿的这件T恤，在《辣妹》里再次出现，作为一种彩蛋。
He holds up a picture of Connie Kotaka, and he says, she is my perfect date. Ready? Here's a description of Connie Kotaka that I found online. Okay. And remember, this is Dwight's idea of the perfect date. All right? This is the perfect woman. The perfect-
他举起一张绀野木孝的照片，然后说，她是我完美的约会对象。准备好了吗？这是我在网上找到的对绀野木孝的描述。好吧。记住，这是德怀特心目中的完美约会对象。好吗？这是完美的女性。完美-
The perfect case, Roots. Perfect woman is go. Okay, ready? Here's a description of her. She was orphaned at the age of 10 when both of her parents were assassinated, then taken in by a wealthy but very cruel businessman, so she practiced a keto in secrecy for years until she could avenge the death of her parents. Wow.
完美的菜，根。完美的女性开始。好吧，准备好了吗？这是对她的描述。她在10岁时父母双双被暗杀，成了孤儿，随后被一个富有但非常残酷的商人家收养，于是她秘密练习合气道多年，直到能够为父母报仇雪恨。哇。
That's Dwight's perfect date. Can we also just, for a minute, none of us knew what it was going to look like when Stanley dribbled the basketball. It was in the script that he is not good at dribbling. That's all. And that Michael would look and just have this moment of like, ah, crap. Like, are you kidding me? And that dribble that Leslie David Baker did.
这就是德怀特的完美约会对象。我们能不能也花一分钟聊聊，当斯坦利运篮球时，谁都不知道会是什么样子。剧本里就写着他很不擅长运球。就这样。而且迈克尔会看着他，流露出一种“啊，糟了”的表情。就像，你在开玩笑吗？莉莉·大卫·贝克（莱斯利·大卫·贝克）运球的那个动作。
With his hand behind him. With his hand behind him. Ridiculous. Ridiculous. It was so perfect. It was literal perfection. Yeah. There's another moment in the basketball game that's coming to mind.
把手背在身后。把手背在身后。太荒谬了。太荒谬了。简直太完美了。简直就是字面意义上的完美。是的。篮球赛里还有另一个画面浮现在我脑海中。
There's a moment where Michael is supposed to, as a joke, it was in the script. He's supposed to like throw the ball from really far. Right. And then go in. Yeah. And then he's supposed to like be all upset, like, ah, I usually make those or whatever. The first time. Do you remember what happened the first time?
有一个镜头是迈克尔本该作为一个笑话把球从很远的地方扔出去，剧本里是这么写的。对。然后球进了。是的。然后他还要表现得很沮丧，比如，啊，我通常都能投进之类的话。第一次。你还记得第一次时发生了什么吗？
Yes. Steve made it. He made it. He made the most ridiculous, like, alley-oop from the other side of the warehouse. And we all cheered. We cheered. And they were like, no, you guys can't cheer. He doesn't make that.
是的。史蒂夫投进了。他投进了。他从仓库的另一端投出了一个最荒谬的空接球。我们所有人都欢呼了。我们欢呼了。然后他们说，不，你们不能欢呼。他根本投不进那种球。
And Steve, I'm sure Steve was like, oh man, I wish that could go in. I know. That should be a deleted scene for sure. I know. That was crazy. Oh, oh, you have to tell about when John actually got hurt. Yes. We actually had a real injury and they just kept the camera rolling.
而且史蒂夫，我敢肯定史蒂夫当时在想，天哪，我真希望那个球能算。我知道。那绝对应该剪进被删片段里。我知道。太疯狂了。哦，哦，你得讲讲约翰真的受伤那次。是的。我们真的发生了一起真实受伤事件，而他们居然让摄像机一直开着。
They did. This was not scripted. It's the part where Roy knocks Jim in the nose and his nose is bleeding. That was just David Denman blocking, like getting a ball and blocking out. There was some real basketball competition when they were playing. So the dude's got a little testosterone. They got a little duty. Yeah.
确实如此。这不是剧本安排的。就是罗伊撞到吉姆的鼻子，导致他鼻子流血的那段。那只是大卫·丹门在卡位，也就是抢球并卡住位置。他们在比赛时真的有激烈的篮球对抗。所以这小伙子们都有点雄性激素。他们有点动真格了。是的。
They got a little duty. But he did. He threw his elbow back, not knowing that John was there and clocked John. And his nose started gushing blood. I think that sound you hear is his nose. I asked Dave Rogers, our editor, yes, because I remember the debate when they were editing this episode. Well, we heard it in real time.
他们确实动真格了。但他真的这么做了。他把手肘往后一甩，根本不知道约翰就在身后，结果狠狠地打中了约翰。然后他的鼻子开始血流如注。我想你们听到的那个声音就是他的鼻子（被打断的声音）。我问过我们的剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯，是的，因为我记得大家在剪辑这一集时有过争论。好吧，我们在现场就听到了。
You can hear it in real life. We were like, dang. Yes. We knew we were like, is his nose broken? Yeah. And we had to pause and like ice pack him. Well, first of all, they didn't stop rolling. They kept documenting it.
你在现实生活中就能听到。我们当时想，天哪。是的。我们当时就知道，在想：他的鼻子断了吗？是的。我们不得不暂停并给他敷冰袋。好吧，首先，他们没有停止拍摄。他们一直在记录。
They kept documenting it. And so we see that John is John ran off because he was in pain and his nose starts bleeding and I didn't know what to do. So I picked up that frickin first aid kit and I walked over to him and then I was like, what am I doing? There's nothing in that kit. There's nothing in that kit. It's like empty.
他们一直在记录。所以我们看到约翰跑开是因为他很痛苦，他的鼻子开始流血，而我当时不知道该怎么办。于是我拿起了那个该死的急救箱，朝他走去，然后我就想，我在干什么？那个箱子里什么都没有。那个箱子里什么都没有。里面简直是空的。
Was that sound really apparently the live audio was not strong enough to use. So they pumped it up. They added a popping sound so that it would more sound like what we heard in real life because I did ask Dave. I was worried John broke his nose. We all were. Yeah. And then they also told me at a certain point they had to stop it where they stopped it
那个声音真的是……显然现场收音不够大，无法使用。所以他们后期放大了声音。他们加了一个“啪”的声音，听起来更像我们在现实生活中听到的声音，因为我确实问过戴夫。我当时很担心约翰的鼻子骨折了。我们所有人都是。是的。然后他们还在某个时候告诉我说他们不得不喊停，因为血滴在地板上，看起来有点血腥。
because blood was dripping on the floor and it looked a little gruesome. Yeah. All right. So I read a great article where David Dynman was asked if he thought he could beat John Krasinski in one on one basketball. Oh, in a real basketball game. Yes. All right.
是的。好吧。所以我读到过一篇很棒的文章，里面问大卫·丹门他觉得自己在一对一篮球赛中能不能打败约翰·克拉辛斯基。哦，在一场真正的篮球比赛里。是的。好吧。
Who would win? What did he say? David or John? So this is a direct quote from David. John, a hundred percent. What? One hundred percent. His whole family, I mean their giants and they're all a basketball family.
谁会赢？他说什么了？大卫还是约翰？这是大卫的原话。约翰，百分之百。什么？百分之百。他的全家，我是说他们个子都是巨人，而且他们全家都是打篮球的。
So no, I'm not even going to pretend to play opposite that I would have a shot. John Krasinski is one of three boys and John is something like six, three. He is the shortest of his brothers. Yes. So here's the thing. John had always told us I'm the shortest in my family and we'd be like, that's crazy year six, three. And then I went to the premiere of Leatherheads, his movie and his whole family came and I
所以，不，我甚至不会假装说我跟他对位会有胜算。约翰·克拉辛斯基家里有三个男孩，约翰身高大概是6英尺3英寸（约1.91米）。他是他兄弟中最矮的一个。是的。事情是这样的。约翰一直告诉我们，我在家里是最矮的，而我们就会说，这太疯狂了，你都有6尺3了。然后我去看了他的电影《皮鞋头》（《爱情达阵》）的首映礼，他全家都来了，然后我
met his brothers and it was ridiculous, they, John, John is the shortest. It's so crazy that he's the rent of the family. He has a brother who's six, six and one who's six, 10. What? His one brother is six, 10? Yes. Yes. I knew they were taller than him, but I mean that is insane.
见到了他的兄弟们，太离谱了，他们，约翰，约翰是最矮的。他竟然是家里最矮的，这太疯狂了。他有一个兄弟身高六英尺六英寸，还有一个六英尺十英寸。什么？他有一个兄弟身高六英尺十英寸？对。是的。我知道他们比他高，但我是说这太疯狂了。
That's insane. John might be like six, four. We had a lot of really tall men on our set actually. David Denman is very tall. Rayne Wilson. John, Rayne Wilson. Brian. Yeah.
太疯狂了。约翰大概六英尺四英寸吧。其实我们片场有很多非常高的男演员。大卫·邓门非常高。雷恩·威尔逊。约翰，雷恩·威尔逊。布赖恩。对。
I mean big guys. Big guys. I will tell you on the office, I wore three inch heels because I was so short whenever I was in scenes next to Rayne Wilson and if you look at Dwight and Angela scenes, a lot of times he is seated and I'm standing. I feel like there were times when they made you stand on a box. Is that true? Yes.
我是说大块头。大块头。我跟你说，在《办公室》里，我穿了三英寸的高跟鞋，因为只要我和雷恩·威尔逊拍对手戏，我就显得太矮了。如果你看德怀特和安吉拉的对手戏，很多时候他是坐着的，而我是站着的。我觉得有时他们会让你站在箱子上。是真的吗？是的。
Did you ever stand on a box to do a scene with him or stand, you would be on stairs and you would be like three stairs up. They had a whole Apple box. They would fly in for me on the ready. I was standing on a box all the time. Okay. Moving on. Moving on.
你有没有为了跟他拍戏而站在箱子上过，或者站着，你得站在台阶上，比平常高出大概三个台阶。他们专门为我准备了一整套苹果箱。随时准备推出来。我一直在箱子上拍戏。好吧。我们继续。继续。
Don't look at my note cards, Jenna. I'm not looking at your note cards. I want you to be surprised. Okay. So I have a note card, Jenna, that you were talking about the boys playing basketball, but actually, you know, there are two women in this game. Of course. Yes.
别看我的小卡片，珍娜。我没有看你的小卡片。我希望你能感到惊喜。好吧。所以我有一张小卡片，珍娜，你之前在说男生们打篮球的事，但其实，你知道，这场比赛里还有两个女人。当然。是的。
Phyllis and Marge. Maj. Maj. And Maj. Marge is from the Simpsons. That's right. Maj. Maj.
菲利斯和玛奇。玛奇。还有玛奇。玛奇是《辛普森一家》里的。没错。玛奇。玛奇。
And her name is Maj Madsen and she is played by Carly Rothenberg who did a fantastic job. What I love so much in the game is I don't know if you noticed when you watched, but Dwight was assigned to man up with Maj. So there's all this great, like, Maj and Dwight. And Dwight, like, regards Maj the way I feel like 12 year old boys regarded me, like, you know, like when the boy, like, like shoves you and is like, hey, and you're like, what? What's the deal? Yeah.
她的名字叫玛奇·马德森，由卡莉·罗滕伯格饰演，她表现得太棒了。我在比赛中最喜欢的一点是，我不知道你看的时候有没有注意到，德怀特被指定去防守玛奇。所以有所有这些精彩的互动，比如玛奇和德怀特。而且德怀特对待玛奇的方式，让我想起12岁小男孩对待我的那种感觉，你知道的，就像那种小男孩推你一下然后说，嘿，然后你会说，什么？怎么回事？对。
He's really physical with her if you watch the game. And she totally gives it right back to him. So anyway, I love that Maj and Phyllis get in the game. I just thought that was really fun to watch. Also we have to talk about Michael's free throw moment. Oh my God. That made me laugh so hard. That is an example of Steve Carell's impeccable comedic timing.
如果你看比赛的话，他跟她有很激烈的身体对抗。而她也毫不客气地直接回击了他。总之，我很喜欢玛奇和菲利斯加入比赛。我只是觉得看这个真的很有趣。另外我们必须谈谈迈克尔的罚球时刻。哦天哪。那把我笑得太惨了。那是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔无可挑剔的喜剧节奏的一个例子。
Yes. He does not rush. He makes you wait for it. You know when he's setting up this ridiculous free throw that it's not going to go in. We all know it's not going to go in. And yet somehow he makes us wait so long that it's even funnier. Yeah. And it's really goes all the way out of the warehouse.
是的。他一点也不着急。他让你拭目以待。你知道当他在做那个荒谬的罚球准备时，这球肯定进不了。我们都知道它肯定进不了。然而不知为什么，他让我们等了那么久，以至于变得更加搞笑了。对。而且这球直接飞出了库房。
He throws it over the whole hoop. And it's great too because you know someone has to run and get that ball. You don't see it happen. But you know that moment when you're playing basketball and someone way overthrows it. And you're like, God, no, I have to go get the, ugh. The basketball episode I think has some of like the best quotes of the whole first season. So many good ones. So many good ones.
他把球扔过了整个篮筐。而且很棒的是，你知道总得有人去跑着把那个球捡回来。你没在画面里看到。但你知道当你打篮球时有人用力过猛把球扔飞了的那种时刻。然后你会想，天哪，不，我得去捡那个，呃。我觉得篮球这一集包含了好几句整个第一季里最棒的台词。有太多精彩的台词了。太多精彩的台词了。
You have one of the best ones that really I've seen on t-shirts and coffee mugs. So I used to sign headshots with this line when people would ask me for my autograph. Do it. Please don't throw garbage at me. I love it. I feel like it sums up Pam's entire relationship with Michael. The fact that she has to say the words, please don't throw garbage at me to her boss. Just it says it all.
你有一句最棒的台词，我真的在T恤和咖啡杯上看到过。以前人们找我要签名时，我常在这行台词旁边签上名字。来一个。请不要向我扔垃圾。我太喜欢了。我觉得这句话完美总结了帕姆和迈克尔的整个关系。她竟然必须对她的老板说出“请不要向我扔垃圾”这句话。这真是一言难尽。
It says it all. And also, you know, it's not the first time she's said it. No, no. Or something like it. That's right. Yeah. And he throws that at your head and goes off the backboard. Yeah.
真是一言难尽。而且你知道，这已经不是她第一次这么说了。不，不。或者类似的话。没错。对。而且他把那个东西朝你脑袋扔过来，还砸中了篮板。对。
So ridiculous. I don't throw garbage at me, Michael. Everything she's had to endure is all in that one line. She's been working there for probably three, four years now. Yeah. Three or four years of garbage thrown at her head and a relationship that's going nowhere. Gosh, it's so, so. Poor Pam.
太离谱了。别向我扔垃圾，迈克尔。她所忍受的一切都在这一句台词里了。她在那儿大概已经工作了三、四年了。对。三四年的垃圾砸在她的脑袋上，还有一段毫无进展的关系。天哪，真是，太。可怜的帕姆。
All right. I don't know. What else can we talk about about basketball, you guys? I do love that this episode ended, of course, with Kevin sinking all of those shots. It was like so great. And yet, nothing in the office is resolved and are they all going to have to work Saturday? He says no one has to come in. Oh, that's right.
好吧。我不知道。大家，关于篮球我们还能聊点什么？我确实很喜欢这一集的结尾，当然是凯文投进了所有那些球。感觉太棒了。然而，办公室里的问题什么都没解决，难道他们所有人周六都得加班吗？他说没有人必须来。哦，对的。
That's right. That's right. He says, he's like, like, we're going to be downsized if we skip one Saturday. Exactly. Everybody is like, wait, what? So you do end on this sense of like, nothing, nothing's okay. Nothing's okay. Nothing's okay.
没错。没错。他说，他就像是，如果少了一个周六，我们就要被裁员了。没错。每个人都一脸茫然，等等，什么？所以你最后确实留下了这样一种感觉，就是一切，一切都不对劲。一切都不对劲。一切都不对劲。
Nothing's really different. And nothing is different. Nothing has been solved. Okay. So that was basketball. That's the basketball episode. That's the basketball episode. I loved watching it again.
一切都没有真正改变。而且一切都没有改变。什么都没有解决。好吧。这就是篮球。这就是篮球那一集。这就是篮球那一集。我重新看了一遍，觉得太棒了。
I have loved watching the show again in general. People come up to us all the time, especially now that the show has been out on Netflix and there's a whole new generation of fans. People really wig out. After so many years, I think I had lost some perspective on how good the show was. I mean, like, I knew it was good, but I hadn't watched it in years. And so because of this podcast, I was forced to sit down and watch these episodes. And now, when people come up to me and tell me the show is good, I'm like, I know.
总的来说，我一直很喜欢重新看这部剧。人们总是来找我们聊天，尤其是现在这部剧在Netflix上播出了，还有全新一代的粉丝。人们真的激动得不得了。过了这么多年，我觉得我有些忽视这部剧到底有多好。我是说，我知道它很好，但我已经好几年没看过它了。所以因为这个播客，我被迫坐下来看了这些集。现在，当人们来告诉我这部剧很好时，我就会说，我知道。
Oh my gosh. It's so good, right? Can you even believe it? Can you believe I was on it? That was me. I was on it. That was so cool. That's so cool.
哦天哪。太棒了，对吧？简直不敢相信吧？你敢相信我曾参演过吗？那是我。我参演了。太酷了。太酷了。
It's amazing. Let's chat about it. Yeah. Yeah. No, absolutely. And I get why it's comfort for people. You know, I really do. You can put it on in the background and it's there.
太神奇了。我们来聊聊吧。对。对。不，绝对的。我理解为什么它能给人们带来慰藉。你知道，我真的理解。你可以在背景里播放它，它就在那里。
And, you know, we've talked about this before, but like Dwight's always going to be Dwight and accounting is accounting and you've got Pam and Jim there and they are, they become your little family in the background as you wind down from your day. I'm so thrilled that the show still keeps finding an audience that just is so wonderful for me and for you and everyone involved. But I have a tiny gripe. What? After re-watching this show.
而且，你知道，我们以前讨论过这个，但德怀特永远都是德怀特，会计部门就是会计部门，帕姆和吉姆也在那儿，当你结束一天的工作想要放松时，他们成了你在背景里的小小家庭。我非常高兴这部剧至今仍在找到观众，这对我、对你以及所有参与其中的人来说都太棒了。但我有一个小小的抱怨。什么？在重新看了这部剧之后。
What? Do you know that not a single actor on our television show ever won an Emmy for their performance on The Office? Oh, we're going there. Excluding Steve Correll. Wait, I was trying to wrap it up. I was trying to wrap it up with a bow. No.
什么？你知道我们电视剧里没有一个演员因为在《办公室》里的表演而获得过艾美奖吗？哦，我们要聊这个了。不包括史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。等等，我本来想好好收尾的。我本来想给它画上一个圆满的句号。不。
And Jim was like, wait, let me bitch for one second. I'm ending with a gripe. Oh, God. Here we go. This is a crime that Steve Correll was never awarded the top prize in his industry for the role of Michael Scott. For the role of Michael Scott. Yeah, I agree.
吉姆就像是，等等，让我吐槽一秒钟。我用一个抱怨来结束。哦，天哪。来吧。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔因为饰演迈克尔·斯科特而从未在业内获得最高奖项，这简直是一场犯罪。因为饰演迈克尔·斯科特。对，我同意。
Because I kind of dare you to name another comedic male performance sort of as revolutionary and heartbreaking and funny and real. Yes. As his performance on that show. No, it was brilliant. He won the Golden Globe, the show won Best Comedy Ensemble, we won an Emmy, we won some SAG awards, but Steve never won an Emmy. And the final year he was nominated because his character was ending, his time on The
因为我简直想向你挑战，看你能不能说出另一个同样具有革命性、让人心碎、搞笑又真实的喜剧男性表演。是的。能比得上他在那部剧里的表演。不，太精彩了。他赢得了金球奖，这部剧赢得了最佳喜剧群戏，我们赢得了一次艾美奖，我们赢得了一些演员工会奖，但史蒂夫从未赢得艾美奖。在他被提名的最后一年，因为他的角色要结束了，他在《办公室》里的时光
Office was ending. It was his final nomination. They had, it was me, you, and John Krasinski in a row on the aisle. And Steve I think was right in front of us or he was down a row and they had a camera on us as they announced the nominees and then they announced the winner and the camera was right on us. And when they didn't say Steve's name, I said Mother Effer out loud. And I am not, I don't curse guys, I'm not a big cursor.
要结束了。那是他的最后一次提名。他们有，我、你和约翰·卡拉辛斯基并排坐在过道上。史蒂夫我想就在我们正前方，或者在前面一排，当他们宣布提名者然后宣布获奖者时，摄像机正对着我们。当他们没有念出史蒂夫的名字时，我大声说出了“妈惹法克”。我不，我平时不骂人，伙计们，我不是一个经常说脏话的人。
And it just flew out of my mouth because I couldn't believe it. And then I was instantly horrified because I thought, oh no, was I just on national television saying Mother Effer, I'm about to get a call from my mom, I know it. And her ladies in her Bible study are going to be like Angela said Mother Effer, but they cut away very fast. So I don't think you saw it. But that's how we felt. We couldn't believe it.
这句话脱口而出，因为我简直不敢相信。然后我立刻感到惊恐，因为我想，天啊，我刚才是不是在全美电视直播里说了“妈惹法克”，我马上就要接到我妈妈的电话了，我知道。她圣经学习班的那些阿姨们肯定会说安吉拉说了“妈惹法克”，但他们切镜头切得非常快。所以我觉得你没看到。但这就是我们的感受。我们简直不敢相信。
We couldn't believe it. Because his work in the show is brilliant and our cast and our writers and everyone, I just, they just did such an amazing job. There you go. Not ending with a nice bow, but there you go. There you go. Next week is Hot Girl. Hot Girl.
我们简直不敢相信。因为他在剧中的表演太精彩了，我们的演员、我们的编剧和所有人，我只想说，他们做的工作太棒了。就这样。没有以一个美好的句号收尾，但就是这样。就是这样。下周是“辣妹”。辣妹。
Amy Adams. Yeah. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Keeper. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Remember you can listen to ad-free versions of Office Ladies on Stitcher Premium.
艾米·亚当斯。对。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基珀。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。记住你可以在Stitcher Premium上收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本。
For a free month of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
免费体验一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码：Office。这一集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。